allerdings gibt es ein paar blöcke das
sind jetzt die einzigen die ich gefunden
habe die ich aufgebaut habe weil ihr
seht ja schon da leuchtet das überall
durch hallo meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen sondern folge
minecraft werkzeug mittwoch nicht am
dienstag gestern weil ich den ganzen tag
unterwegs war dass es irgendwie immer so
dass ich quasi mittlerweile immer
unterwegs bei den ganzen tag in dortmund
auch schöne grüße an alle die mich dort
erkannt haben war cool mit euch und die
sache ist halt ich habe immer ich sage
immer am dienstag kommen direkt aber die
kommen falls sie noch mittwoch aber wenn
ich jetzt sagen würde die com am
mittwoch dann wäre das gleiche das sich
mit wasser weg bin und dass wir noch am
donnerstag kommt deswegen sage ich sie
kommen dienstag oder mittwoch ich
versuche dienstag zu schaffen sonst
kommen sie am mittwoch also setzt sich
da nicht zu viel im kopf und meckert
nicht so viel rum weshalb man nicht
kommt aber ich würde dann sagen dass wir
direkt auch anfangen irgendwann in
dieser folge wird wieder ein geräusch
vorkommen was ihm in die kommentare
schreiben könnt dann werde ich dann auch
sagen wer das letzte mal das erraten hat
und so irgendwann in dieser folge des
volkes zu ende anschauen vielleicht
kommt er diesmal am ende ich bei so
einer ladung ist schneiders koch ich
schneide das ganze ist ein
produktionsstudio muss man ja mal dazu
sagen manche leute keine ironie
verstehen jedenfalls bedanke ich mich
schon mal bei allen leuten die mir die
sachen zu gesendet haben sind wieder
sehr sehr cool effect sex könnte mir ein
kontrast gmail.com senden und ich kann
hier nicht dafür garantieren dass die
facts dass ihr die nicht schon gesehen
hat dass sie das nicht schon wisst dass
das ganze schon andere videos
vorgekommen ist die ganze serie besteht
aus euren facts deswegen bin ich da
keiner schuld bewusst wenn da irgendwas
von irgendwem anders wenn dir das doch
schonmal gesehen habe habe ich würds
angefangen mit dem ersten werk von
monster hunter und zwar wenn ihr ein
boot habt und ihr setzt ist ja ganz
normal hier ins wasser dann ich bin hier
bei uns ein bisschen gesagt kann ich
hier so ganz normal rumfahren so negativ
wenn ich irgendwo gegen fahrer geht das
boot dementsprechend kaputt das ist aber
nicht perfekt sondern wenn ich ein boot
auch auf land setze also zumindest geht
es auf diesen quatsch blöcken die ich
hier mein allerdings haben dann kann ich
mich daran setzen auch das ist jetzt
natürlich erst mal ein bisschen verpackt
das ist jetzt gerade nicht sogar momente
ich danke ganz kaputt
ich setze das hirn ich setze mich da
rein und ich kann dann immer so ein
bisschen rum fahren ihr seht dass ich
bin das boot dreht sich zwar nicht wenn
ich hierhin gehe dass es im wasser
drehte sich dann ja dadurch dreht sich
dann die richtung wo man gerade
hinfahren will
es bleibt in der position wie es
hingesetzt habe und man sitzt du auch so
ein bisschen verbuggt drin als wenn man
halt im wasser aber man bewegt sich was
bewegt sich zwar langsam aber man kann
damit fahren und man verliert dabei auch
keinen hunger
man sitzt quasi in dem boot und kann
darauf so ein bisschen fahren das ist
hat minecraft gemacht weil wenn man hier
irgendwie am rand ist oder so und also
ich würde es mal so erklären dass man
das boot wenn man das ein bisschen an
setzte dann trotzdem ins wasser kommt
weil sich mein mann kann sich ja nur
noch ein bisschen reinschieben
das ganze funktioniert allerdings nur
wenn man diese fall tasten drückt also
nicht wenn ich jetzt wohin gucke da kann
es ja auch sein dass man in die richtung
fährt ich kann auch dahin gucken und
kann aber nach hinten drücken
und jetzt bin ich halt im wasser und in
jeder folge fing es an zu regnen
das ist doch mal so traurig und jetzt
packen sich hier die erinnern mehr darum
bachmann
naja ich auf jeden fall danke an dich
monster hunter das ist auf jeden fall
ein perfekt und man kann das boot quasi
dann so als auto benutzen man verpisst
euch doch
sz wie das akku ich finde es ist alles
super geil los mit diesem sheik das ist
alles richtig schön zweiter effekt wurde
mit zugesendet von backbone imec ball
irgendwie so um den dreh und zwar kennt
es wenn ihr irgendwie was ein geben
wollt oder das mittlerweile geht das
hier so gar nicht nur an alle skripte
oder an alle server macher sondern auch
eine ganz normale leute kennt das wenn
ihr auf der serverseite / habe oder
irgendwie sowas geht jetzt kann ich mich
auf den server bin allerdings man muss
immer drücken und dann shift gedrückt
halten und dann dieses diesen
schrägstrich machen
das ist alles total doof man kann auch
einfach hashtag drücken also das ist die
taste die links untere taste von enter
rechts das ist die hashtag hast und dann
ist man direkt in dem chat drin
mit dem schrägstrich also wenn ihr den
zukunft einfach auf dem server seiten zu
maniche wird zum sport einfach hashtag
und gibt spontan weil es bauern einmal
muss man nicht mal über den etwas
längeren umweg tee und dann schiff
gedrückt halten dann dieses dieser
schrägstrich also das ist auf jeden fall
eine coole sache die haben das leben
wirklich ein bisschen erleichtert und
das ist echt nummer drei wurde mir
zugesendet von niklas aus dem saarland
und zwar bieten es können ja durch alle
transparenten blöcke durch stellen also
glas oder luft aber sie strahlen auch
durch einen zauber tisch durch
eigentlich unlogisch oder niklas ich
habe noch ein paar mehr sachen aus
gefunden und hab ich einfach mal ein
bisschen herumprobiert wie kennst ja
ganz normal wenn wir bieten blockern
komme ich war das ganze thema mal eben
kurz den kleinen auf so ewig kennen es
wenn ich einen bieten blog habe dann
musste ja immer auch so ein paar seht
euch mal leuchtfeuer video einfach an
und auf die auf diesem material den oder
den da bleibt keine unterrichtsstunde
hier sondern und wenn ich dann einen
schwamm zum beispiel darauf setzte dann
wird das ganze hier gleich blockiert
moment da alles blockiert ich kann auch
einen quartz blog darauf setzen dass das
ganze auch blockiert oder ich lasse es
ganz mal eben kurz hoch strahlend ich
kann da auch eine fichtenholz stufe
beispielsweise draufsetzen und ist das
ganze nämlich ebenfalls blockiert so da
könnte mich keine ganz normale blöcke
drauf weil das ganze dann würde verdeckt
wird und der muss immer irgendwie den
himmel leuchten der leuchtet übrigen
glaube ich 248 blöcke hoch oder 2050
gegen die sonne drehe jeden fall sehe
ich die höhe nicht aber das ganz coole
ist mit dem shader komma der leuchtet
das licht ist ein bisschen daneben das
ein bisschen crazy
egal also ihr seht schon das klappt
eigentlich nicht allerdings gibt es ein
paar blöcke das sind jetzt die einzigen
die ich gefunden habe
die ich hier gerade aufgebaut habe weil
ihr seht ja schon da leuchtet das
überall durch das ist egal ich kann das
hier auch wegnehmen und wieder drauf
setzen
geil wie ich das daneben setze ich kann
das darauf wieder ich muss ein bisschen
mit shift wieder drauf setzte es ist
egal das möchte der ball durch und zwar
hab ich einfach mal so ein paar blöcke
probiert und ich denke das sind die
einzigen weil ich habe jetzt
beispielsweise auch tnt probiert oder
redstone blog oder so ein spender oder
ganz normale sachen wolle oder so da
geht's halt nicht durch es geht durch
ein versorgungsschiff sowie der niklas
mir schon geschrieben hat durch ganz
normales glas das ist jetzt einfach
getöntes glas und das ist diese
gleichschalten also da geht es halt
durch als transparente blöcke sind
allerdings ist es halt krass das ist
auch durch eine verzauberung tisch durch
eine ganz normale kiste durch eine ende
kiste
durch diese cent portal rahmen teil
durch den amboss durch ein bett und
durch ein tages lichtsensor geht es
ebenfalls durch das heißt quasi könnt
euch im bieten blog wenn ihr im bett
unterm sternenhimmel habt könnt ihr euch
ein bieten blog einfach euer bett setzen
dass da unten ist immer so ein bisschen
des lebens im inventar cannoli wohl am
shader oder irgendwie eine kiste noch
drauf oder so das ist doch egal ich kann
auch die kiste neben geht da unten
draufpacken moment macht es einen ganz
kurzen so kann auch da unten hin setzen
das geht trotzdem alles noch weiter das
ist auf jeden fall eine krasse sache
dass es alles durch diese blöcke
trotzdem durchgeht und das ganze
erinnert mich übrigens gerade an dieses
das gebäude london ist quasi einfach nur
so eine riesige steine pyramide ich
feiere übrigens bald nach london
darüber wird er übernächste kontakt
handeln dann machen wir einen kleinen
follow me round in london und so freue
ich mich schon richtig auf das ganze
zusammen zu schneiden
auf jeden fall dann kann dich nicht dass
wir den weg ich will nicht abweichen und
wir machen direkt mit dem wirt effekt
jetzt wieder der black screen für das
geheimnisvolle geräusche wenn ich
angelangt seid erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch
das letzte geheimnisvolle geräusche
erraten von romani viva oder romani war
ich weiß nicht sie hat geschrieben du
trinkst aus einer flasche und das ganze
schon nach zwei minuten also relativ
stand am anfang richtig gut von die
romani romina romania weise nicht das
geheimnis von der geräusch für diese
folge ist dass hier viel spaß beim raten
schreibt es einfach unten in die
kommentare wenn ihr jetzt erwacht und
eventuell sind in der nächsten folge
vorbei und jetzt viel spaß weiterhin bei
den
den effekt auch sehr sehr cool
zugesendet von chat oder samtig
tschuldigung ich hoffe ich spreche das
rad richtig aus und zwar wenn man einen
blumentopf mit einer blume drin aufs
mausrad klickt bekommt man keinen
blumentopf sondern was in den top ten
war aber wenn dort nichts drin ist dann
bekommt man ganz normal ein blumentopf
ihr kennt das ganz normal das mache ich
ja immer da wenn ich auch selbst oft
gefragt wie ich das denn machen wenn ich
auf einen block drauf gucke wie ich den
bug bekommen aber drückt ihr einfach
teurer mausrad drückt da drauf wenn ihr
das nicht kennt bei ramos dann könnt ihr
seid nicht machen aber ich glaube kann
das umstellen einstellungen und dann
bekommt man halt den blog auf dem einrad
drauf guckt wenn man den boxen hat dann
wird man dahin teleportiert zu diesem
blog wo man den gerade hat also nicht
importiert sondern dann wird man dazu
inventar eingepackt soll das ganz kurz
erst mal grundlegend
und wenn ich jetzt hier blumentopf
hatten die selbst hin und okay ich habe
jetzt ein blumentopf noch ein inventar
also ich mach da mit dem mausrad drauf
dann habe ich halt ein blumentopf wenn
ich allerdings in diesem blumentopf was
drin habe denkt man sich ja eigentlich
erst mal okay wenn ich auf diese
setzlingen drauf gucke und die mittlere
maustaste drücken dann kriegt den
setzlingen wenn ich da so drauf gucke
wenn ich auf dem blumentopf drauf gucke
jetzt ist der blondschopf jahr anvisiert
dann kriegt ihr blumentopf wenn ich
allerdings hier mittlere maustaste
darauf mache bekomme ich ein fichten
setzlingen das liegt nicht an diesem
setzling sondern genau das gleiche ist
auch bei einer roten tulpe oder bei
einer blauen das ist genauso oft ich
gucke hier drauf auf den blumentopf und
bekommen nur das was quasi in dem kopf
drin ist weil wenn ich hier oben drauf
drückt ihr seht ihr schon der nimmt das
nicht als blog an
wenn ich diesen setzling hier so
irgendwo hinsetzen würde moment machen
wir ganz kurzen gras blocken einmal ganz
kurz und rasputin jetzt wird es ganz
sicher als block anvisiert ihr seht doch
schon hier so ganz ins blog kann ich
drauf steht dann habe ich denen klasse
hier ist das allerdings nicht als
blogger das ist ja nur eine verkleinerte
variante von der wirklichen dingsbums
und das bedienen wir nicht als block
angesehen sondern nur das was dahinter
ist das heißt sie bekommen dann einen
quartz blog also wenn irgendwas in einem
blumentopf drin ist könnt ihr über diese
mittlere maustaste funktion nur das
bekommen was in den blumentopf drin ist
dann müsst ihr erst das irgendwie kaputt
schlagen aber auch wenn ihr das kaputt
schlag weil es geht ja nur im gaylord 1
mit dem mittlere maustaste funktionen im
survival mode 0 also zwei bord geht das
ganz ehrlich da kann man sich nicht sich
nicht einfach hinten blog nehmen müsste
erst das kaputt schlagen was da drin ist
allerdings wenn ich im creative bin
kaputt
das heißt wenn ihr im blumentopf etwas
rinderdung creative und den ich auch das
inventar zurückgreifen können könnt ihr
euch den blumentopf nicht mehr holen
weil er dann immer nur das kriegt was da
drin ist und auf jeden fall danke an die
ich schaue mir das an
aber richtig freuen die schulden waren
aber was das war es dann auch wird der
heutigen minecraft facts folge passend
zum sonnenuntergang ging mal wieder ich
glaube es ging war eigentlich nochmal
lang die folge ich hoffe euch hat
gefallen wenn ja dann zeigt mir wird mag
ich schaffen wir vielleicht 2000 daumen
hoch dass wir super wir uns jetzt mal
auch schon geschafft das ist echt
richtig geil das zeigt mir quasi immer
dass ihr diese ferien dass die ferien
feiert die feier de
die feierlich auch zur zeit dass ich
frei habe aber dass ihr diese serie
feiert das ist sehr sehr schön soll das
ist übrigens ein sehr schöner anblick
jetzt hier gerade das manchmal so für
die ent card also wenn es euch gefallen
hat mir wirklich mit dem daumen hoch
dafür dass ihr mehr davon wollte nächste
folge kommt hoffentlich nächsten
dienstag ich hoffe es dass ich schaffe
weil ich ja die nächste woche montag den
ganzen tag in london bin und dann hoffe
ich dass ich am dienstag schaffe wenn
ich da nicht doch total nicht jetlag
aber total müde bin und alles sonst
kommt es am mittwoch also immer
dienstags oder mittwochs von crafter
gmail.com ich hoffe das geheimnisvolle
geräusche raten dann schreibt uns in die
kommentare
und wir sehen uns dann in der nächsten
video wieder die sonne geht unter